[Music]
nadine was standing in the blank gray
cubicle
trying to decide where to hang her
motivational calendar
when she spotted a shadow flitting in
the corner of her vision
this was followed seconds later by a
thunderous crash
nadine looked up startled to see a
hunched old man with red rimmed eyes
wearing a crooked yellow tie and two
days of beard growth
he had dropped something on the edge of
the u-shaped desk that's what the noise
had been
welcome to the company he gruffed nadine
pursed her lips at him
what's this she was already turning the
noisy thing toward her
it was a tome thicker than a manhattan
telephone directory
with a solid black cover and thick white
type with a red outline
employee handbook my goodness it
certainly looks thorough
the old man breathed in and out a few
times sending clouds of alcoholic air
wafting toward nadine
he flapped his hand at her nobody reads
that thing he said
then dropped a seedy wink at her and
stalked away grumbling to himself
nadine stood very straight in the middle
of her tiny new domain smoothing
non-existent wrinkles out of her brown
pencil skirt
the cubicle walls were even with her
eyebrows she could only see over by
standing on tiptoe and craning her neck
but this was an indignity she refused to
allow herself
all she could discern of her fellow
employees was the rhythmic and discreet
clacking of their computer keyboards
which never seemed to stop even for an
instant
no voices buzzed no phones jingled there
was just that incessant clacking
at last she hefted the handbook off the
corner of her desk and placed it primly
next to her own computer
she glanced back at her still empty
inbox then bent over the handbook
flipping open the black cover riffling
through the pages
a smile curled one side of her mouth if
no one read the thing well that was all
for the better
nadine had every intention of being the
first one in the company to read the
entire book
from table of contents through index she
got as far as the second page before an
enormously fat woman with a brassy and
uneven die job lumbered by
and slammed a gigantic pile of paperwork
into nadine's inbox
she closed the handbook reluctant to
leave its dry descriptions of rules and
responsibilities
but glad of something more productive to
do she tackled the pile with clawed
hands
two hours later she had processed every
single application
the entire stack now sat neatly in her
outbox
pleased with herself nadine leaned back
in her chair crossing her nylon-clad
legs and resuming her handbook study
exactly where she'd ended it
the red-headed fat woman waddled by
again her fish lips pink and puckering
and snatched the pile from the outbox
with one meaty hand
she said nothing and nadine returned the
favor
for the rest of the morning work came in
at a steady trickle and nadine polished
each stack off in record time
her fingers flying across her keyboard
none of the other employees spoke to her
or commented on her efficiency
but nadine needed no praise for her
efforts conscientiousness was its own
reward
by the time lunch rolled around she had
worked her way through a quarter of the
handbook
taking detailed notes where company
policy differed from the norm
all in all though the company seemed
much like any other and its sameness
gave nadine a sense of placid
satisfaction
marking her page with a paperclip she
went to retrieve a small carton of
yogurt from the cafeteria refrigerator
speaking to no one because she passed no
one on her short journey
the other employees were surely having
lunch at this time also
because the clacking was noticeably
diminished but she had no idea where
they had gone
shrugging she carried the yogurt back to
her desk carefully propping the handbook
in front of her so she could read while
she ate
in the middle of a passably titillating
paragraph about sexual harassment laws
nadine swore she saw the type beginning
to squirm and dance across the page
frowning she put down her spoon and
removed her reading glasses
cleaning them thoroughly with a white
cloth from her handbag
after a moment she donned her glasses
again and stared at the page
the type had stopped swimming but now
she was sure the paragraph said
something different than it had a moment
ago
whereas before the words had clearly
described procedures for reporting
inappropriate behavior by a co-worker
now they just as clearly read
first floor ladies room mirror lower
left edge
retrieve object and consult handbook for
instructions
nadine tapped a lacquered fingernail on
her chin
she was not given to illusions and she
was sure that text had changed
but how could it have while she was
looking right at it
she glanced up then made a complete
circle in her office chair
staring around with narrowed eyes even
though she could see nothing but the
sides of her cubicle
with someone playing a joke on her
having a laugh at the expense of the new
meet
she huffed and turned back to the book
well
obviously it was telling her to do
something she knew where the first floor
ladies room was
she'd passed it after signing in at the
front desk this morning
she had probably even used it when she
came for her interview several weeks ago
looking back again seeing no one
checking that her inbox was still
empty she got out of her chair very
deliberately and left the office
she thought about taking her handbook
along but how mortifying would that look
carrying the massive volume to the
ladies room
she headed out into the main hallway her
back straight her stride bold
she passed no one although she could
hear the ubiquitous clack of computer
keys behind some of the closed office
doors
the ladies room was cool and silent with
a vaguely floral scent hovering in the
air
that served to cover up another smell
something rank and coppery
nadine wrinkled her nose for a moment
she considered going through the motions
of stepping into a stall
but then abandoned the idea that she
couldn't help but feel that she was
being watched from the overhead air
vents she scoffed at herself but the
sensation persisted
the mirror was large spanning four sinks
and was mounted slightly away from the
wall with brackets
nadine started at the site of her own
reflection which appeared nearly green
under the bright florescence
combing her hands through her dark hair
she began visually inspecting the left
corner of the mirror
and then unable to contain her curiosity
any longer
she plunged her fingers greedily into
the gap between the glass and the
wallpaper
at first she felt nothing but dust and a
sort of sticky substance like epoxy
intermingled with old spider silk
the corner of the mirror scraped her
fingers until the blood welled just
beneath the surface
and she cursed under her breath
listening to the weird echoes her voice
made
at last a raised shape materialized
under her straining grasp
and with a strangled yip she pulled it
free and stuck it under the faucet
rinsing off the worst of the gunk it was
a coin
not like any coin she'd ever seen but
clearly some sort of token or monetary
piece
it was a rather tarnished gold color and
heavy she speculated that it might be
made of brass
it didn't look very old and a close
inspection gave no clue as to the date
of its issue
the front of the coin bore an etched
image of what appeared to be a circle
with several overlapping triangles
pointing inward around the perimeter
rather like the mouth of a lamprey the
back was blank except for a small number
in the center
one three one nadine thought she heard
the bathroom door creak open
and nearly dropped the coin down the
sink drain but the sound was only some
machinery perhaps the central air
conditioning
humming to life somewhere in the bowels
of the building
she slid the coin into her blouse pocket
and then washed her hands twice
trying to dislodge the oily feel of the
metal from her fingers
she had no idea what the coin meant or
what she was supposed to do with it
but she hoped the handbook would tell
her what she needed to know
it was still in the back of her mind
that this might be some sort of joke
but her interest had been peaked and she
saw no harm in continuing the game
if only for a little while back at her
desk there was another pile of work
waiting for her
and she silently cursed herself for
being absent when another employee
perhaps a superior
had happened by she didn't want rumors
starting that she was undependable
prone to wandering the halls when she
was supposed to be working
she considered asking the person in the
next cubicle something about their
restrooms
so he or she would know that's where
she'd been but in the end she skipped it
sliding into her chair she set to her
work immediately racing through the
forms as quickly as she could manage
without making
mistakes finally she placed the last
sheet into her outbox
and then began massaging her hands which
ached from being cramped over the
keyboard
she hadn't really thought of it until
now but the forms she processed were odd
unlike any she'd seen in other companies
where she'd worked
she wasn't entirely sure what the
applications were for and no one had
told her precisely
an employee simply filled in the
information from the form into empty
fields in the computer program
some of the information was mundane name
address marital status
but some was unusual asking about crimes
committed political affiliations belief
systems
nadine had always thought those types of
questions were illegal but perhaps the
applicants were being assessed for
top-secret clearance
it was a far-fetched explanation nadine
knew but it was all she could think of
a stooping man with a handlebar mustache
appeared like magic
at the entrance to her cubicle
disturbing her reverie
he didn't speak to her even look at her
simply whisked away the stack of papers
she'd just finished
nadine considered calling him back just
to say something to someone
but she kept her mouth shut as much as
she was unsettled by the silence of her
coworkers
she was also afraid some of them would
find out about her private scavenger
hunt with the employee handbook
best to keep to herself for now she
thought
nadine went back to the book her skin
flushed with excitement
she had marked the page where the type
had changed and she thumbed back to it
now
but her shoulders sagged as she saw
nothing further written there about what
she had found
the paragraph simply resumed the subject
of sexual harassment
as if the clue about the coin wasn't
even there
frowning nadine skipped ahead a few
pages skimming as she went
but still she saw nothing relevant to
her search and no repeat of the swimming
text that might signify a pending change
she swore under her breath tapping her
fingernails on the desktop
what was this she closed the book then
opened it again
but that didn't do anything either
apparently the bewitchman of the
handbook had run its course
and how is she to know that the clues
she'd gotten so fired up about was
nothing more than a run-of-the-mill
printing error
she closed the book for good feeling
deflated
the coin felt strangely warm against her
chest so she drew it out of her pocket
and stared at it
there was the lamprey mouth or whatever
it was she turned the coin over
the number of course her heart speeding
up to a gallop
she eagerly flipped to page 131 in the
handbook and was almost immediately
rewarded by the sight of the black
letters contorting and rearranging
themselves into new patterns
this time in the middle of a section
discussing the 401k plan
the following words appeared snack
machine
second level insert coin choose d6
consult handbook terse but perfectly
clear
unable to get rid of the smile that had
bloomed on her face nadine hopped from
her seat
not caring whether anyone was watching
her or not her entire body felt inflamed
with the thrill of discovery
she scooped the handbook up in her arms
turning the cover toward her chest
no one had ever read it that's what the
alcoholic man this morning had told her
well she was the first one to read it
and she was going to be the first one to
solve the mystery it posed
she almost wanted to duck into the other
cubicles let her co-workers know what
they'd been missing
but no she breezed out of the office and
down the hallway heading for the
staircase
perhaps she mused whoever had written
the handbook wish to reward the
diligence of employees who actually
cared enough about their jobs
to be informed about the company they
worked for perhaps nadine speculated
further her gait increasing
she would even get a raise or a
promotion once it was discovered what
she had done
the second floor was as deserted as the
first and although nadine had been
trying to tell
herself she wasn't bothered by this now
she had to admit it unnerved her
where was everyone certainly there was a
lot of work to be done
and most people were probably holed up
in their offices with their own stacks
of applications
but surely someone had to walk through
the halls sometime to deliver paperwork
or go to the restroom or get a cup of
coffee
but nadine passed no one and heard
nothing except for that infernal
clacking
that now sounded as loud as a jackhammer
in her ears
the snack machine glowed sullenly near
the end of a darkened hall
and nadine approached her palms sweaty
on the handbook spine
the inside of the machine appeared to be
coated with a thick layer of dust
as did the few dispirited candy bars and
potato chip packets that remain behind
the coiled metal springs
she paused for only a moment then
dropped the bronze coin into the slot
listening as it rattled its way into the
guts of the machine
then with one perk finger she pressed d6
on the lighted panel
the machine wheezed to life the spring
uncoiling reluctantly
and releasing what looked to be a
crumpled bag of stale pretzels
nadine scowled but stuck her hand into
the slot to retrieve them
almost wishing she had kept the coin at
least it might have had some value
beyond the caloric she was going to
examine the package right then and there
but she was mindful of the time she was
spending away from her desk
and even though there was no one around
at present to see her she still didn't
wish to be spotted on a floor where she
had no reason to be
nadine barely glanced at the bag before
grasping it in her sweaty hand
and trotting back down the stairs to her
office
thankfully no more paperwork had
materialized in her absence
and with an avid gaze she studied the
pretzel package
wincing at the gunshot crackle of the
plastic as she handled it
the label on the bag was gibberish or at
least written in a language nadine had
never seen before
rife with bizarre symbols and angry
looking letter strokes
the front bore a window through which
the unappetizing product could be seen
and in the corner of this window was a
printed red starburst
containing the numbers 304 in white
without a pause she flipped to page 304
of the handbook
open bag bulletin board third level near
human resources office
insert find into board return to
handbook
nadine had to restrain herself from
tearing the bag open leery of attracting
attention
instead she grabbed a pair of scissors
from a cup on her desk
and sliced open the plastic she rooted
around in the bag
grimacing at the mushy feel of the
pretzels on her fingers
after a moment she jumped gasping
something in the bag had bitten her
or at least that's what it felt like
nadine pulled a tissue from the box on
her desk and dumped the contents of the
entire bag upon it
the offending object was an ordinary
push pin albeit one of the fancy
metallic ones
this one was a glimmering cherry red she
palmed the pin
scraping bag tissue and pretzels into
the garbage can
she then made sure she buried the
evidence under some other waste paper
just in case anyone was rooting around
in her trash while she was gone
she almost laughed aloud at her paranoia
but she couldn't quite manage it
this time she took the elevator up
thereby lessening her chances of being
seen in the halls
she again carried the handbook clasped
in her arms
the ancient elevator car creaked and
grown through the floors
its lighted numbers flickering like one
candlelight
nadine thought she smelled that coppery
odor she'd noticed in the bathroom but
then it was gone
the pin was pushing into the flesh of
her palm almost as though it was trying
to dig through to the other side
the elevator door is shuttered open on
an even darker hallway than the ones
below
and she stepped out painfully aware of
the click of her high heels on the dingy
linoleum floors
she could easily become lost in this
building she thought as she maneuvered
through what seemed like endless
twisting halls
all apparently identical to one another
rose upon rows of fading neon bulbs and
closed office doors with nothing but
clacking and rustling coming from behind
them
she remembered coming up here to the
human resources office once
to fill out the benefits forms but had
the hallways seemed so sinister then
and hadn't she seen smiling employees
buzzing to and fro
at the end of a very long corridor the
kind in dreams where you never come to
the end
there stood a single gray door marked
human resources
the lights over the door seemed to have
winked out completely but even so nadine
thought the words on the door were
handwritten
sloppily in what appeared to be black or
red paint
she shuffled closer and sure enough on
the side wall leading up to the door was
a bulletin board
its cork grimed with dirt it's only
posting a flyer for a blood drive
that had taken place nearly six years
before
hesitantly nadine poked the red pin into
the bulletin board
glancing over her shoulder into the
darkness as soon as the pin had
penetrated the cork
the board gave a shrill creak and then
rotated forward
almost hitting her on top of the head as
it moved she thought she glimpsed
something behind the board as it swung
something black and red and writhing a
flash of silver
but it was gone as quickly as it had
materialized the smell here was worse
than ever
she shivered the board clicked into
place
displaying its back which looked almost
exactly like the front
except that the cork was even dirtier
and there was no blood drive poster
instead right where the point of the pin
had emerged there was an impaled
business card
white with metallic red lettering she
pulled it free from the pinpoint
squinting to read it in the dimness
pinnacle
4-1-7 taking another quick glance around
nadine opened the handbook page 417
rearranged itself to read
report to top level type password into
keypad
congratulations the last word danced in
front of her eyes
teasing congratulations for what was
this the end of the line
would there be some reward waiting for
her when she got to the top level
she glanced down at her watch it was
almost four o'clock
and she'd been away from her desk for a
while now should she go back
and check on the workload she started to
weaving her way through the maze of
hallways and back to the elevator
poising her finger over the ground floor
button but in the end her curiosity won
out she pressed the button marked top
the elevator lurched to life once again
seeming to resent her presence inside
and carried her up one level though the
journey seemed to take an inordinately
long time
nadine was starting to think the damn
thing was broken and she'd be trapped in
an elevator on her first day at work
but then the doors slid open revealing a
very long carpeted hallway
the darkest of all the corridors she had
visited lit only by a few discreet
sconces
the silence up here was not as profound
as the lower levels
for a moment she fancied she heard
raised voices and the distant hum of
machinery again
though it didn't sound so much like the
air conditioning system now
clutching the handbook to her chest like
a shield she pressed forward
trying to project more confidence than
she felt
the book after all had congratulated her
on her acuity in figuring out the clues
so surely she was heading for her just
reward so thinking she approached the
ornate door at the end of the hall
the tiny keypad next to it glowed red
and she typed the word pinnacle into its
minuscule memory
it seemed to consider her attempt for a
fraction of a second
then glowed green approvingly the door
in front of her clicked and swung
silently inward at first the room inside
was so dark that she could see nothing
but slowly more sconces to either side
begin to light up of their own accord
and nadine could see that she'd stepped
into a vast office
carpeted in dark red and sparsely
furnished with a mahogany desk and chair
at which no one was sitting the room had
no windows
and the carpet appeared unmarked by
footprints
she crept forward reluctant to call out
knowing how her voice would sound
echoing weirdly back at her
she noticed that the office had no doors
or exits other than the one she'd just
come through
and that its only aesthetic flourish was
a large painting hung on the wall behind
the desk
its subject matter was too dim for
nadine to make out
as she approached the desk she noted a
few objects arranged neatly on its
eerily clean surface
a brass nameplate a stack of papers that
looked like the type of forms that
nadine had been working on all morning
an empty out box and a set of two
buttons set partially into the wood
one red one green there was no phone
no computer no other paraphernalia that
would suggest that business was
conducted here
she still heard voices and a sort of
reedy whine that might have been crying
but she couldn't determine where the
sounds were coming from other than that
it was somewhere behind the walls
she wondered if she should simply wait
for someone to come or whether there was
some action she was supposed to be
taking
she glanced down at the handbook in her
arms
then peering guiltily around she sat at
the desk
feeling the leather chair opening to
receive her and then closing lovingly
around her contours
she settled in flipping back to the page
in the book where she'd read the last
instructions
she scanned page 417 where the lines
describing the password had been before
now there was nothing but a mundane
rundown of the accumulation of sick time
frantically nadine rifled through the
book looking for some hint of the clues
that had led her on this crazy
expedition
page 131 page 304 nothing
nothing remained of the mysterious
instructions nothing at all
the handbook was just that a boring
employee handbook
she slammed it closed and sat back hard
in the chair which seemed to stiffen in
response to her fury
had all this been her imagination no she
thought she had seen those words change
seeing what those words had said besides
if it had all been imagined how had she
known the password to get in here
she leaned forward again propping her
elbows on the desk clutching her head
between her hands
she knew she wasn't going insane she
wouldn't even let herself think that
there had to be some other explanation
nadine realized she'd been staring at
the brass nameplate on the edge of the
desk for a long moment without realizing
what it said
she blinked then took off her glasses
and cleaned them again
rubbing them so hard she was afraid the
lenses would crack
when she had them back on she pulled the
nameplate toward herself
and tilted it under the meager light it
was handsome and grave script
deeply scored into the brass nadine
graham
ceo nadine's head swam
and for a second she actually thought
she might faint right onto the untouched
red carpet
surely she was seeing things she rubbed
her finger over the letters
feeling the indented lines and loops of
her name definite and real
surely this was also an elaborate
practical joke then
she looked around the office her gaze
suspicious suddenly certain that her
co-workers were gathered somewhere right
now
watching her on a hidden camera laughing
obscenely at her confusion
had they all planned this in advance
scheming messing around with her
handbook
keeping to themselves in their cubicles
all day purposely not speaking to her
why would they do this she had never met
any of them before today
she couldn't help it if she worked
faster was more efficient
better at her job why did everyone
always try to drag her down
as she was pondering these questions
staring at her name in the brass so hard
that her eyes were beginning to ache
she noticed that the green button
embedded in the desk had begun to flash
startled she leaped out of the chair
smoothing her skirt down as though she'd
been caught in an office tryst
the button flashed insistently almost
angrily and she thought the voices
behind the walls got louder too
although that might have been her
fraying nerves making her hear things
panicked she scooped up her handbook as
though it was a security blanket
and took three trotting steps back
toward the door she'd entered through
it had closed when she wasn't looking
and she froze halfway to it
would she be able to get out maybe the
green button opened the door
she reasoned and then hurried back to
the desk to press it
the door to the office didn't open but
the walls around her
certainly did nadine watch slackjawed as
the paneled walls began sliding back
along hidden tracks
revealing massive glass panes the
painting behind the desk which nadine
could now see depicted a bashian scene
of sinners being swallowed up by flames
and tormented by capering demons
disappeared into the ceiling along with
the remainder of the wall
at first the glass was dark windows
looking out into nothingness
but then lights begin flickering on
nadine gasped
she was looking out over a huge chasm
like an enormous circular shaft that
appeared to extend down into the lower
levels of the building
and perhaps even farther the office
itself seemed to be perched like an arie
suspended over this unsettling drop
nadine shuffled nearer
reluctant to look down even though the
glass protected her from falling
the bottom was far below and difficult
to see but as more lights came on along
the shaft
the picture became clearer the lamprey
mouth
it was at the bottom of the shaft only
it was made of metal
an immense round hole studded with
silver blades
all glinting and hungry ma'am
she nearly screamed as a man's voice
shoved aside the silence of the office
her gaze darted around finally homing in
on two small black
intercom speakers mounted unobtrusively
in the corners near the ceiling
she cleared her throat yes i where are
you
the office below you miss graham are we
ready to proceed
nadine hugged the book to her chest
proceed
i don't perfectly all right ma'am the
voice
was deep and rumbling business-like but
patient
there should be a stack of forms on your
desk there the applications ma'am
nadine set her handbook down on the
counter and picked up the first form
from the pile
it was one she had processed earlier she
was sure of it yes
can you read me off the name that's on
the top of the form ma'am
of course kevin linden thank you
just a moment the sound she'd heard
earlier the crying grew
louder and then another sound the hum of
machinery
started up somewhere below her feet the
floor of the office shook a little
her throat felt very dry kevin lyndon
ma'am
for a moment nothing happened but then
nadine almost screamed again
as a man was lowered into view through
the glass wall
he was suspended by his arms from a set
of chains that was fastened somewhere
far above him
his eyes were swollen as though he'd
been repeatedly punched
but he seemed to be conscious if just
barely
blood trickled slowly from the corner of
his mouth
as she watched the humming mechanism
lurched causing the man to slide toward
her
as though the chains were attached to
some sort of track overhead
then the machine stopped with a jerk and
the man hung there
mumbling something that she couldn't
quite hear
it seemed like an eternity passed as she
stood there staring at the man
he stared back at her his dark eyes
uncomprehending
filled with agony and please she didn't
know quite what was happening
and for a moment she thought she might
be dreaming she felt as though she had
left her body and was floating above
herself
above the office building looking down
from a wreath of clouds
the voice from the intercom brought her
back to reality
any time you're ready ms graham she tore
her gaze away from the man's
and noticed that the red button was now
flashing on the desk
what will happen when i push that she
asked herself
but of course she already knew she moved
away from it involuntarily
her hand squeezing the handbook so hard
that she left deep grooves in the
cardboard cover
we have a lot of applicants to get
through this afternoon ma'am said the
voice
and now an edge of impatience was
apparent the deep tones barely masking a
sense of threat
no one else can finalize the
applications miss graham
you're the boss the words flitted to and
fro in her brain
leaving little red streaks as they went
the boss
this was her reward for diligence this
was the end she'd been striving for
the man kevin linden hung there before
her his shoulders creaking with the
strain of suspension
his face a mask of despair but also she
thought
of resignation she glanced down at the
form in her hand
scanning mr linden's personal
information
not a bad man not really but he had
transgressed
and transgressions should be punished
she had always thought so
always resented people who got away with
breaking the rules
and now here he was a life hanging in
the balance
a fate delivered into her hands she
suddenly felt very calm
ms graham the voice from the intercom
was almost a shout
yes i'm sorry nadine glided back to the
desk
placing the handbook down in the middle
of the blotter she didn't know if she
would read it all now
now that she had made it to the top
alright we can proceed
with only a moment's hesitation she
punched the flashing red button with all
the force she could muster
all at once the chains holding kevin
linden let go
and the man went screaming down the
shaft flailing his arms and legs like a
[ __ ] marionette
nadine averted her gaze as he hit bottom
with a slick thud
and as an even louder machinery came to
life grinding and clashing
far below where she stood the blades did
their work quickly and efficiently
stopping and allowing themselves to be
cleaned by an automatic sprayer
until they were silver and shining again
eager for their next applicant
nadine feeling sick but strangely light
lowered herself into the leather chair
which seemed as though it had been made
expressly for her body
she placed kevin linden's form into the
outbox and then she picked up the next
one
and read the name aloud
it was never quite clear to me how jim
shorthouse managed to get his private
secretary ship
but once he got it he kept it and for
some years he led a steady life and put
money in the savings bank
one morning his employer sent for him
into the study and it was evident to the
secretary's trained senses that there
was something unusual in the air
mr shorthouse he began somewhat
nervously
i have never yet had the opportunity of
observing whether or not you are
possessed of personal courage
shorthouse gasped but he said nothing he
was growing accustomed to the
eccentricities of his chief
shorthouse was a kentish man sidebotham
was raised in chicago
new york was the present place of
residence
but the other continued with a puff at
his very black cigar
i must consider myself a poor judge of
human nature in future
if it is not one of your strongest
qualities
the private secretary made a foolish
little bow in modest appreciation of so
uncertain a compliment mr jonas b
sidebotham watched him narrowly as the
novelists say
before he continued his remarks i have
no doubt that you were a plucky fellow
and he hesitated and puffed at his cigar
as if his life depended upon keeping it
alight
i don't think i'm afraid of anything in
particular sir except women interposed
the young man
feeling that it was time for him to make
an observation of some sort but still
quite in the dark as to his chief's
purpose
humph he grunted well there are no women
in this case so far as i know
but there may be other things that that
hurt more
once a special service of some kind
evidently was the secretary's reflection
personal violence he asked aloud
possibly
puff in fact puff puff
probably short house smelt an increase
of salary in the air
it had a stimulating effect i've had
some experience of that article sir
he said shortly but i'm ready to
undertake anything
in reason i can't say how much reason or
unreason there may prove to be in this
particular case
it all depends mr sidebotham got up and
locked the door of his study
and drew down the blinds of both windows
then he took a bunch of keys from his
pocket
and opened a black tin box he ferreted
about among blue and white papers for a
few seconds
enveloping himself as he did so in a
cloud of blue tobacco smoke
i feel like a detective already short
house laughed
speak low please return the other
glancing around the room
we must observe the utmost secrecy
perhaps you would be kind enough to
close the registers
he went on in a still lower voice open
registers have betrayed conversations
before now
shorthouse began to enter into the
spirit of the thing he tiptoed across
the floor
and shut the two iron gratings in the
wall that in american houses supply hot
air and are termed registers
mr sidebotham had meanwhile found the
paper he was looking for
he held it in front of him and tapped it
once or twice with the back of his right
hand
as if it were a stage letter and himself
the villain of the melodrama
this is a letter from joel garvey my old
partner
he said at length you have heard me
speak of him
the other bowed he knew that many years
before
garvey and sidebotham had been well
known in the chicago financial world
he knew that the amazing rapidity with
which they accumulated a fortune
had only been surpassed by the amazing
rapidity with which they had immediately
afterwards disappeared into space
he was further aware his position
afforded facilities
that each partner was still to some
extent in the other's power
and that each wished most devoutly that
the other
would die the sins of his employer's
early years did not concern him however
the man was kind and just if eccentric
and short house
being in new york did not probe to
discover more particularly the sources
once his salary was so regularly paid
moreover the two men had grown to like
each other and there was a genuine
feeling of trust and respect between
them
i hope it's a pleasant communication sir
he said in a low voice
quite the reverse return the other
fingering the paper nervously as he
stood in front of the fire
blackmail i suppose precisely
mr sidebotham's cigar was not burning
well he struck a match and applied it to
the uneven edge
and presently his voice spoke through
clouds of wreathing smoke
there are valuable papers in my
possession bearing his signature
i cannot inform you of their nature but
they are extremely valuable to me
they belong as a matter of fact to
garvey as much as to me
only i've got them i see
garvey writes that he wants to have his
signature removed
wants to cut it out with his own hand he
gives reasons which incline me to
consider his request
and you would like me to take him the
papers and see that he does it
and bring them back again with you he
whispered screwing up
his eyes into a shrewd grimace and bring
them back again with me
repeated the secretary i understand
perfectly
shorthouse knew from unfortunate
experience more than a little of the
horrors of blackmail
the pressure garvey was bringing to bear
upon his old enemy
must be exceedingly strong that was
quite clear
at the same time the commission that was
being entrusted to him seemed somewhat
quixotic in its nature
he had already enjoyed more than one
experience of his employer's
eccentricity
and he now caught himself wondering
whether the same eccentricity did not
sometimes go
further than eccentricity i cannot read
the letter to you
mr sidebotham was explaining but i shall
give it into your hands
it will prove that you are my my
accredited representative
i shall also ask you not to read the
package of papers
the signature in question you will find
of course on the last page
at the bottom there was a pause of
several minutes during which the end of
the cigar glowed eloquently
circumstances compel me he went on at
length almost in a whisper
or i should never do this but you
understand of course
the thing is a ruse cutting out the
signature is a mere pretense
it is nothing what garvey wants are the
papers themselves
the confidence reposed in the private
secretary was not misplaced
shorthouse was as faithful to mr
sidebotham as a man ought to be to the
wife that loves him
the commission itself seemed very simple
garvey lived in solitude
and the remote part of long island
shorthouse was to take the papers to him
witness the cutting out of the signature
and to be especially on his guard
against any attempt
forcible or otherwise to gain possession
of them
it seemed to him a somewhat ludicrous
adventure but he did not know all the
facts
and perhaps was not the best judge the
two men talked in low voices for another
hour at the end of which mr sidebotham
drew up the blinds
opened the registers and unlocked the
door
short house rose to go his pockets were
stuffed with papers and his head with
instructions
but when he reached the door he
hesitated and turned
well said his chief shorthouse looked
him straight in the eye
and said nothing the personal violence i
suppose
said the other short house bowed
i have not seen garvey for 20 years he
said
all i can tell you is that i believe him
to be occasionally of
unsound mind i have heard strange rumors
he lives alone and in his lucid
intervals studies chemistry
it was always a hobby of his but the
chances are 20 to 1 against his
attempting violence
i only wish to warn you in case i mean
so that you may be on the watch
he handed his secretary a smith and
wesson revolver as he spoke
shorthouse slipped it into his hip
pocket and went out of the room
a drizzling cold rain was falling on
fields covered with half-melted snow
when shorthouse stood late in the
afternoon on the platform
of the lonely little long island station
and watched the train he had just left
vanish into the distance it was a bleak
country that joel garvey esquire
formerly of chicago had chosen for his
resonance
and on this particular afternoon it
presented a more than usually dismal
appearance
an expanse of flat fields covered with
dirty snow stretched away on all sides
till the sky dropped down to meet them
only occasional farm buildings broke the
monotony
and the road wound along muddy lanes and
beneath dripping trees
swathed in the cold raw fog that swept
in like a pall of the dead from the sea
it was six miles from the station to
garvey's house and the driver of the
rickety buggy short house had found at
the station
was not communicative between the dreary
landscape and the dreary or driver
he fell back upon his own thoughts which
but for the spice of adventure that was
promised
would themselves have been even drearier
than either
he made up his mind that he would waste
no time over the transaction
the moment the signature was cut out he
would pack up and be off
the last train back to brooklyn was 7 15
and he would have to walk the six miles
of mud and snow
for the driver of the buggy had refused
point blank to wait for him
for purposes of safety short house had
done what he flattered himself was
rather a clever thing
he had made up a second packet of papers
identical and outside appearance with
the first
the inscription the blue envelope the
red elastic band
and even a blot in the lower left hand
corner had been exactly reproduced
inside of course were only sheets of
blank paper
it was his intention to change the
packets and to let garvey see him put
the sham one into the bag
in case of violence the bag would be the
point of attack and he intended to lock
it and throw away the key
before it could be forced open and the
deception discovered there would be time
to increase his chances of escape with
the real packet
it was five o'clock when the silent
driver pulled up in front of a
half-broken gate
and pointed with his whip to a house
that stood in its own grounds among
trees
and was just visible in the gathering
gloom shorthouse told him to drive up to
the front door
but the man refused i running no risks
he said i've got a family this cryptic
remark was not encouraging
but shorthouse did not pause to decipher
it he paid the man
and then pushed open the rickety old
gate swinging on a single hinge
and proceeded to walk up the drive that
lay dark between close standing trees
the house soon came into full view it
was tall and square
and had once evidently been white but
now the walls were covered with dirty
patches
and there were wide yellow streaks where
the plaster had fallen away
the windows stared black and
uncompromising into the night
the garden was overgrown with weeds and
long grass
standing up in ugly patches beneath
their burden of wet snow
complete silence reigned overall there
was not a sign of life
not even a dog barked only in the
distance
the wheels of the retreating carriage
could be heard growing fainter and
fainter
as he stood in the porch between pillars
of rotting wood
listening to the rain dripping from the
roof into the puddles of slushy snow
he was conscious of a sensation of utter
desertion and loneliness
such as he had never before experienced
the forbidding aspect of the house had
the immediate effect of lowering his
spirits
it might well have been the abode of
monsters or demons in a child's wonder
tale
creatures that only dared to come out
under cover of darkness
he groped for the bell handle or knocker
and finding neither he raised his stick
and beat a loud tattoo on the door the
sound echoed away in an empty space on
the other side
and the wind moaned past him between the
pillars as if startled at his audacity
but there was no sound of approaching
footsteps and no one came to open the
door
again he beat a tattoo louder and longer
than the first one
and having done so waited with his back
to the house and stared across the
unkempt garden
into the fast gathering shadows then he
turned suddenly
and saw that the door was standing ajar
it had been quietly
opened and a pair of eyes were peering
at him round the edge
there was no light in the hall beyond
and he could only just make out the
shape of a dim human face
does mr garvey live here he asked in a
firm voice
who were you came in a man's tones
i'm mr cybotham's private secretary i
wish to see mr garvey on important
business
are you expected i suppose so
he said impatiently thrusting a card
through the opening
please take my name to him at once and
say i come from mr sidebotham on the
matter mr garvey wrote about
the man took the card and the face
vanished into the darkness
leaving shorthouse standing in the cold
porch with mingled feelings of
impatience and dismay
the door he now noticed for the first
time was on a chain
and could not open more than a few
inches but it was the manner of his
reception that caused uneasy reflections
to stir within him
reflections that continued for some
minutes before they were interrupted by
the sound of approaching footsteps
and the flicker of a light in the hall
the next instant the chain fell with a
rattle
and gripping his bag tightly he walked
into the large ill-smelling hall
of which he could only just see the
ceiling there was no light but the
flickering taper held by the man
and by its uncertain glimmer shorthouse
turned to examine him
he saw an undersized man of middle age
with brilliant shifting eyes
a curling black beard and a large nose
his shoulders were bent and as he
watched him replacing the chain
he saw that he wore a peculiar black
gown like a priest's cassock
reaching to his feet it was altogether a
lagubrious figure of a man
sinister and funerial yet it seemed in
perfect harmony with the general
character of its surroundings
the hall was devoid of furniture of any
kind and against the dingy walls stood
rows of old picture frames
empty and disordered and odd looking
bits of woodwork that appeared doubly
fantastic
as their shadows danced queerly over the
floor in the shifting light
if you'll come this way mr garvey will
see you presently
said the man gruffly crossing the floor
and shielding the taper with a bony hand
he never once raised his eyes above the
level of the visitor's waistcoat
and to short house he somehow suggested
a figure from the dead
rather than a man of flesh and blood the
hull smelt decidedly ill all the more
surprising then was the scene that met
his eyes when the man opened the door at
the further end
and he entered a room brilliantly lit
with swinging lamps
and furnished with a degree of taste and
comfort that amounted to luxury
the walls were lined with handsomely
bound books and armchairs were arranged
around a large mahogany desk in the
middle of the room
a bright fire burned in the great and
neatly framed photographs of men and
women stood on the mantelpiece on either
side of an elaborately carved clock
french windows that opened like doors
were partially concealed by warm red
curtains
and on a sideboard against the wall
stood decanters and glasses
with several boxes of cigars piled on
top of one another
there was a pleasant odor of tobacco
about the room
indeed it was in such glowing contrast
to the chilly poverty of the hall
that shorthouse already was conscious of
a distinct rise in the thermometer of
his spirits
then he turned and saw the man standing
in the doorway with his eyes fixed upon
him
somewhere about the middle button of his
waistcoat he presented a strangely
repulsive appearance that somehow could
not be attributed to any particular
detail
and the secretary associated him in his
mind with a monstrous black bird of prey
more than anything else my time is short
he said abruptly i hope mr garvey will
not keep me waiting
a strange flicker of a smile appeared on
the man's ugly face
and vanished as quickly as it came he
made a sort of deprecating bow by way of
reply
then he blew out the taper and went out
closing the door noiselessly behind him
shorthouse was alone he felt relieved
there was an air of obsequious insolence
about the old man that was very
offensive
he began to take note of his
surroundings he was evidently in the
library of the house
for the walls were covered with books
almost up to the ceiling
there was no room for pictures nothing
but the shining backs of well-bound
volumes looked down upon him
four brilliant lights hung from the
ceiling and a reading lamp with a
polished reflector stood among the
disordered masses of papers on the desk
the lamp was not lit but when shorthouse
put his hand upon it he found it was
warm
the room had evidently only just been
vacated
apart from the testimony of the lamp
however he had already felt without
being able to give a reason for it
that the room had been occupied a few
moments before he entered
the atmosphere over the desk seemed to
retain the disturbing influence of a
human being
an influence moreover so recent that he
felt as if the cause of it were still in
his immediate neighborhood
it was difficult to realize that he was
quite alone in the room
and that somebody was not in hiding the
finer counterparts of his senses warned
him to act as if he were being observed
he was dimly conscious of a desire to
fidget and look around
to keep his eyes in every part of the
room at once and to conduct himself
generally as if he were the object of
careful human observation
how far he recognized the cause of these
sensations it is impossible to say
but they were sufficiently marked to
prevent his carrying out a strong
inclination to get up and make a search
of the room
he sat quite still staring alternately
at the backs of the books
and at the red curtains wondering all
the time if he was really being watched
or if it was only the imagination
playing tricks with him
a full quarter of an hour passed and
then 20 rows of volume suddenly shifted
out towards him
and he saw that a door had opened in the
wall opposite
the books were only sham backs after all
and when they moved back again with the
sliding door
short house saw the figure of joel
garvey standing before him
surprise almost took his breath away he
had expected to see an
unpleasant even a vicious apparition
with a mark of the beast unmistakably
upon its face
but he was wholly unprepared for the
elderly tall fine looking man who stood
in front of him
well-groomed refined vigorous with a
lofty forehead
clear gray eyes and a hooked nose
dominating a clean-shaven mouth
and a chin of considerable character a
distinguished looking man altogether
i'm afraid i've kept you waiting mr
short house he said in a pleasant voice
but with no trace of a smile in the
mouth or eyes
but the fact is you know i i'm a mania
for chemistry
and just when you were announced i was
at the most critical moment of a problem
and was really compelled to bring it to
a conclusion
shorthouse had risen to meet him but the
other motioned him to resume his seat
it was born in upon him irresistibly
that mr joel garvey
for reasons best known to himself was
deliberately lying
and he could not help wondering at the
necessity for such an elaborate
misrepresentation
he took off his overcoat and sat down
i've no doubt too that the door startled
you garvey went on
evidently reading something of his
guest's feelings in his face
you probably had not suspected it it
leads into my little laboratory
chemistry is an absorbing study to me
and i spend most of my time there
mr garvey moved up to the armchair on
the opposite side of the fireplace
and sat down shorthouse made appropriate
answers to these remarks
but his mind was really engaged in
taking stock of mr sybotham's old
old-time partner
so far there was no sign of mental
irregularity
and there was certainly nothing about
him to suggest violent wrongdoing
or coarseness of living on the whole mr
sidebotham's secretary was most
pleasantly surprised
and wishing to conclude his business as
speedily as possible
he made a motion towards the bag for the
purpose of opening it
when his companion interrupted him
quickly you are mr cybotham's private
secretary
are you not he asked shorthouse replied
that he was
mr sidebotham he went on to explain has
entrusted me with the papers in the case
and i have the honor to return to you
your letter of a week ago
he handed the letter to garvey who took
it without a word and deliberately
placed it in the fire
he was not aware that the secretary was
ignorant of its contents
yet his face betrayed no signs of
feeling
shorthouse noticed however that his eyes
never left the fire until the last
morsel had been consumed
then he looked up and said you are
familiar then with the facts of this
most peculiar case
shorthouse saw no reason to confess his
ignorance
i have all the papers mr garvey he
replied taking them out of the bag
and i should be very glad if we could
transact our business as speedily as
possible
if you will cut out your signature i one
moment please
interrupted the other i must before we
proceed further
consult some papers in my laboratory if
you will allow me to leave you alone a
few minutes for this purpose
we can conclude the whole matter in a
very short time
shorthouse did not approve of this
further delay but he had no
option than to acquiesce and when garvey
had left the room by the private door
he sat and waited with the papers in his
hand
the minutes went by and the other did
not return
to pass the time he thought of taking
the false packet from his coat to see
that the papers were in order
and the move was indeed almost completed
when something he never knew what
warned him to desist the feeling again
came over him that he was being watched
and he leaned back in his chair with a
bag on his knees
and waited with considerable impatience
for the other's return
for more than 20 minutes he waited and
when it length the door
opened and garvey appeared with profuse
apologies for the delay
he saw by the clock that only a few
minutes still remained of the time he
had allowed himself to catch the
last train now i am completely at your
service
he said pleasantly you must of course
know mr shorthouse that one cannot be
too careful in matters of this kind
especially he went on speaking very
slowly and impressively
in dealing with a man like my former
partner whose mind as you doubtless may
have discovered is at times very sadly
affected
short house made no reply to this he
felt that the other was watching him
as a cat watches a mouse it is almost a
wonder to me
garvey added that he is still at large
unless he is greatly improved it can
hardly be safe for those who are closely
associated with him
the other began to feel uncomfortable
either this was the other side of the
story
or it was the first sides of mental
irresponsibility
all business matters of importance
required the utmost care
in my opinion mr garvey he said at
length cautiously
ah then as i thought you have had a
great deal to put up with from him
garvey said with his eyes fixed on his
companion's face
and no doubt he is still as bitter
against me as he was years ago when the
disease first showed itself
although this last remark was a
deliberate question and the questioner
was waiting with fixed eyes for an
answer shorthouse elected to take no
notice of it
without a word he pulled the elastic
band from the blue envelope with a snap
and plainly showed his desire to
conclude the business as soon as
possible
the tendency on the other's part to
delay did not suit him at all
but never personal violence i trust mr
shorthouse
he added never i'm glad to hear it
garvey said in a sympathetic voice very
glad to hear it
and now he went on if you are ready we
can transact this little matter of
business before dinner
it will only take a moment he drew a
chair up to the desk and sat down
taking a pair of scissors from a drawer
his companion approached with the papers
in his hand
unfolding them as he came garvey at once
took them from him
and after turning over a few pages he
stopped and cut out a piece of writing
at the bottom of the last sheet but one
holding it up to him short house read
the words joel garvey
in faded inc there that's my signature
he said and i've cut it out it must be
nearly 20 years since i wrote it
and now i'm going to burn it he went to
the fire and stooped over to burn the
little slip of paper
and while he watched it being consumed
shorthouse put the real papers in his
pocket
and slipped the imitation ones into the
bag garvey turned just in time to see
this latter movement
i'm putting the papers back short house
said quietly
you've done with them i think certainly
he replied as completely deceived
he saw the blue envelope disappear into
the black bag
and watched shorthouse turn the key they
no longer have the slightest interest
for me
as he spoke he moved over to the
sideboard and pouring himself out a
small glass of whiskey
asked his visitor if he might do the
same for him but the visitor declined
and was already putting on his overcoat
when garvey turned with genuine surprise
on his face
you surely are not going back to new
york tonight mr short house
he said in a voice of astonishment i've
just time to catch the 7 15 if i'm quick
but i never heard of such a thing garvey
said of course i took it for granted
that you would stay the night
it's kind of you said short house but
really i must return tonight
i never expected to stay the two men
stood facing each other garvey pulled
out his watch
i'm exceedingly sorry he said but upon
my word i took it for granted you would
stay
i ought to have said so long ago i'm
such a lonely fellow and so little
accustomed to visitors that i fear i
forgot my manners altogether
but in any case mr shorthouse you cannot
catch the 7 15
for it's already after six o'clock and
that's the last train tonight
garvey spoke very quickly almost eagerly
but his voice sounded genuine there's
time if i walk quickly
said the young man with decision moving
towards the door
he glanced at his watch as he went
hither too
he had gone by the clock on the
mantelpiece to his dismay he saw that it
was
as his host had said long after six the
clock was half an hour slow
and he realized at once that it was no
longer possible to catch the train
had the hands of the clock been moved
back intentionally
had he been purposely detained
unpleasant thoughts flashed into his
brain
and made him hesitate before taking the
next step his employer's warning rang in
his ears
the alternative was six miles along a
lonely road in the dark
or a night under garvey's roof the
former seemed a direct invitation to
catastrophe
if catastrophe there was planned to be
the latter
well the choice was certainly small one
thing however he realized was plain
he must show neither fear nor hesitancy
my watch must have gained he observed
quietly turning the hands back without
looking up
it seems i have certainly missed that
train and shall be obliged to throw
myself upon your hospitality
but believe me i had no intention of
putting you out to any such extent
i'm delighted the other said defer to
the judgment of an older man and make
yourself comfortable for the night
there's a bitter storm outside and you
don't put me out at all
on the contrary it's a great pleasure i
have so little contact with the outside
world that it's really a godsend to have
you
the man's face changed as he spoke his
manner was cordial and sincere
shorthouse began to feel ashamed of his
doubts and to read between the lines of
his employer's warning
he took off his coat and the two men
moved to the armchairs beside the fire
you see garvey went on in a lowered
voice i understand your hesitancy
perfectly
i didn't know sidebotham all those years
without knowing a good deal about him
perhaps more than you do i've no doubt
now
he filled your mind with all sorts of
nonsense about me
probably told you that i was the
greatest villain on hong e and all that
sort of thing
poor fellow he was a fine sword before
his mind became unhinged
one of his fancies used to be that
everybody else was insane
or just about to become insane is he
still as bad as that
few men replied shorthouse with the
manner of making a great confidence but
entirely refusing to be drawn
go through his experiences and reach his
age without entertaining delusions of
one kind or another
perfectly true said garvey your
observation is evidently keen
very keen indeed shorthouse replied
taking his cue neatly
but of course there are some things and
here he looked cautiously over his
shoulder
there are some things one cannot talk
about too circumspectly
i understand perfectly and respect your
reserve
there was a little more conversation and
then garvey got up and excused himself
on the plea of superintending the
preparation of the bedroom
it's quite an event to have a visitor in
the house and i want to make you as
comfortable as possible
he said marx will do better for a little
supervision
and he added with a laugh as he stood in
the doorway
i want you to carry back a good account
to side bottom
the tall form disappeared and the door
was shut
the conversation of the past few minutes
had come somewhat as a revelation to the
secretary
garvey seemed in full possession of
normal instincts
there was no doubt as to the sincerity
of his manner and intentions
the suspicions of the first hour began
to vanish like mist before the sun
sidebotham's portentous warnings and the
mystery with which he had surrounded the
whole episode
had been allowed to unduly influence his
mind
the loneliness of the situation and the
bleak nature of the surroundings had
helped to complete the illusion
he began to be ashamed of his suspicions
and a change commenced gradually to be
wrought in his thoughts
anyhow a dinner and a bed were
preferable to six miles in the dark
no dinner and a cold train into the
bargain
garvey returned presently we'll do the
best we can for you
he said dropping into the deep armchair
on the other side of the fire
marx is a good servant if you watch him
all the time you must always stand over
him though
if you want things done properly he's
tricky and uncertain unless he's working
for his own interest
he's been with me for nearly 20 years
cook valet housemaid and butler all in
one
in the old days you know he was a clerk
in our office in chicago
garvey rattled on and short house
listened with occasional remarks thrown
in the former seemed pleased to have
somebody to talk to
and the sound of his own voice was
evidently sweet music in his ears
after a few minutes he crossed over to
the sideboard and again took up the
decanter of whiskey
holding it to the light you will join me
this time he said pleasantly
pouring out two glasses it will give us
an appetite for dinner
and this time house did not refuse the
liquor was mellow and soft and the men
took two glasses apiece
excellent remarked the secretary glad
you appreciate it
said the host smacking his lips it's
very old whiskey and i rarely
touch it when i'm alone but this he
added
is a special occasion isn't it
shorthouse was in the act of putting his
glass down
when something drew his eyes suddenly to
the other's face
a strange note in the man's voice caught
his attention and communicated alarm to
his nerves
a new light shone in garvey's eyes and
there flitted momentarily across his
strong features
the shadow of something that set the
secretary's nerves tingling
a mist spread before his eyes and the
unaccountable belief rose strong in him
that he was staring into the visage of
an untamed animal
close to his heart there was something
that was wild fierce and savage
an involuntary shiver ran over him and
seemed to dispel the strange fancy as
suddenly as it had come
he met the other's eyes with a smile the
counterpart of which in his heart was
vivid horror
it is a special occasion he said as
naturally as possible
and allow me to add a very special
whiskey
garvey appeared delighted he was in the
middle of a devious tale describing how
the whiskey came originally into his
possession
when the door opened behind them and a
grating voice announced that dinner was
ready
they followed the classic form of marks
across the dirty hall
lit only by the shaft of light that
followed them from the library door
and entered a small room where a single
lamp stood upon a table laid for dinner
the walls were destitute of pictures and
the windows had venetian blinds without
curtains
there was no fire in the great and when
the men sat down facing each other
shorthouse noticed that while his own
cover was laid with its due
proportion of glasses and cutlery his
companion had nothing
before him but a soup plate without fork
knife or spoon beside it
i don't know what there is to offer you
he said but i'm sure marx has done the
best he can at such short notice
i only eat one course for dinner but
pray take your time
and enjoy your food marx presently set a
plate of soup before the guest
yet so loathsome was the immediate
presence of this old servant
that the spoonfuls disappeared somewhat
slowly
garvey sat and watched him shorthouse
said the soup was delicious and bravely
swallowed another mouthful
in reality his thoughts were centered
upon his companion
whose manners were giving evidence of a
gradual and curious change
there was a decided difference in his
demeanor a difference that the secretary
felt at first rather than saw
garvey's quiet self-possession was
giving place to a degree of suppressed
excitement
that seemed so far inexplicable his
movements became quick and nervous
his eyes shifting and strangely
brilliant and his voice when he spoke
betrayed an occasional deep tremor
something unwanted was stirring within
him
and evidently demanding every moment
more vigorous manifestation as the meal
proceeded
intuitively short house was afraid of
this growing excitement
and while negotiating some uncommonly
tough pork chops
he tried to lead the conversation onto
the subject of chemistry
of which in his oxford days he had been
an enthusiastic student
his companion however would have none of
it it seemed to have lost interest for
him
and he would barely condescend to
respond when marx presently returned
with a plate of steaming eggs and bacon
the subject dropped of its own accord an
inadequate dinner dish garvey said as
soon as the man was gone
but better than nothing i hope
shorthouse remarks that he was
exceedingly fond of bacon and eggs
and looking up with the last word saw
that garvey's face was twitching
convulsively
and that he was almost wriggling in his
chair he quieted down however under the
secretary's gaze
and observed though evidently with
effort very good of you to say so
wish i could join you only i never eat
such stuff i only take one course for
dinner
shorthouse began to feel some curiosity
as to what the nature of this one course
might be
but he made no further remark and
contented himself with noting mentally
that his companion's excitement seemed
to be rapidly growing beyond his control
there was something uncanny about it and
he began to wish he had chosen the
alternative of the walk to the station
i'm glad to see you never speak when
marx is in the room said garvey
presently i'm sure it's better not to
don't you think so he appeared to wait
eagerly for the answer
undoubtedly said the puzzled secretary
yes the other went on quickly he's an
excellent man but he has one drawback
a really horrid one you may but no
you could hardly have noticed it yet not
drank i trust
said shorthouse who would rather have
discussed any other subject than the
odious servant
worse than that a great deal garvey
replied evidently expecting the other to
draw him out
but shorthouse was in no mood to hear
anything horrible
and he declined to step into the trap
the best of servants have their faults
he said coldly i'll tell you what it is
if you like
garvey went on still speaking very low
and leaning forward over the table
so that his face came close to the flame
of the lamp only we must speak quietly
in case he's listening
i'll tell you what it is if you think
you won't be frightened
nothing frightens me he laughed garvey
must understand that at all events
nothing can frighten me he repeated i'm
glad of that
for it frightens me a good deal
sometimes shorthouse feigned
indifference
yet he was aware that his heart was
beating a little quicker and that there
was a sensation of chilliness in his
back
he waited in silence for what was to
come
he has a horrible predilection for
vacuums garvey went
on presently in a still lower voice and
thrusting his face farther forward under
the lamp
vacuums exclaimed the secretary in spite
of himself
what in the world do you mean what i say
of course
he's always tumbling into them so that i
can't find him or get at him
he hides there for hours at a time and
for the life of me i can't make out what
he does there
short house stared his companion
straight in the eyes what in the name of
heaven was he talking about
do you suppose he goes there for a
change of air or or to escape
he went on in a louder voice short house
could have laughed outright but for the
expression of the other's face
i should not think there was much air of
any sort in a vacuum
he said quietly that's exactly what i
feel
continued garvey with ever-growing
excitement that's the horrid part of it
how the devil does he live there you see
have you ever followed him there
interrupted the secretary
the other leaned back in his chair and
drew a deep sigh
never it's impossible you see i can't
follow him
there's not room for two a vacuum only
holds one comfortably
marx knows that he's out of my reach
altogether once he's fairly inside
that is the drawback to a servant of
course shorthouse spoke slowly with his
eyes on his plate
a drawback interrupted the other with an
ugly chuckle
i call it a draw in that's what i call
it
a draw in does seem a more accurate term
a scented shorthouse
but he went on i thought that nature
abhorred a vacuum
she used to when i was at school though
perhaps it's so long ago
he hesitated and looked up something in
garvey's face
something he had felt before he looked
up stopped his tongue and froze the
words in his throat
his lips refused to move and became
suddenly dry
again the mist rose before his eyes and
the appalling shadow dropped its veil
over the face before him
garvey's features began to burn and glow
then they seemed to coarsen
and somehow slip confusably together he
stared for a second
it seemed only for a second into the
visage of a ferocious and abominable
animal
and then as suddenly as it had come the
filthy shadow of the beast passed off
the mist melted out and with a mighty
effort over his nerves he forced himself
to finish his sentence
you see it's so long since i've given
attention to such things
he stammered his heart was beating
rapidly and a feeling of oppression was
gathering over it
it's my peculiar and special study on
the other hand garvey resumed
i've not spent all these years in my
laboratory to no purpose i can assure
you
nature i know for a fact he added with
unnatural warmth
does not a pour a vacuum on the contrary
she's uncommonly fond of them
much too fond it seems for the comfort
of my little household
if there were fewer vacuums and more
abhorrence we should get on better
a damned sight better in my opinion your
special knowledge no doubt enables you
to speak with authority
shorthouse said curiosity and alarm
warring with other mixed feelings in his
mind
but how can a man tumble into a vacuum
you may well ask that's just it how can
he
it's preposterous and i can't make it
out at all marx knows but he won't tell
me
for my part i have reason to believe he
stopped and listened
hush here he comes he added rubbing his
hands together as if in glee
and fidgeting in his chair steps were
heard coming down the passage
and as they approached the door garvey
seemed to give himself completely over
to an excitement he could not control
his eyes were fixed on the door and he
began clutching the tablecloth with both
hands
again his face was screened by the
loathsome shadow
it grew wild wolfish as through a mask
that concealed and yet was thin enough
to let through a suggestion of the beast
crouching behind
there leaped into his countenance the
strange look of the animal and the human
the expression of the werewolf the
monster
the change in all its loathsomeness came
rapidly over his features
which began to lose their outline the
nose flattened
dropping with broad nostrils over thick
lips the face rounded
filled and became squat the eyes which
luckily for short house no longer sought
his own
glowed with the light of untamed
appetite and bestial greed
the hands left the cloth and grasped the
edges of the plate
and then clutched the cloth again this
is my course coming now
said garvey in a deep guttural voice he
was shivering
his upper lip was partly lifted and
showed the teeth white and gleaming
a moment later the door opened and marks
hurried into the room and set a dish in
front of his master
garvey half-rose to meet him stretching
out his hands and grinning horribly
with his mouth he made a sound like the
snarl of an animal
the dish before him was steaming but the
slight vapor rising from it betrayed by
its odor that it was not born of a fire
of coals it was the natural heat of
flesh
warmed by the fires of life only just
expelled
the moment the dish rested on the table
garvey pushed away his own plate
and drew the other up close under his
mouth then he seized the food in both
hands and commenced to tear
it with his teeth grunting as he did so
shorthouse closed his eyes with a
feeling of nausea
when he looked up again the lips and jaw
of the man opposite were stained with
crimson
the whole man was transformed a feasting
tiger starved and ravenous but without a
tiger's grace
this was what he watched for several
minutes transfixed with horror and
disgust
marx had already taken his departure
knowing evidently what was not good for
the eyes to look
upon and shorthouse knew at last that he
was sitting face to face with a madman
the ghastly meal was finished in an
incredibly short time
and nothing was left but a tiny pool of
red liquid rapidly hardening
garvey leaned back heavily in his chair
inside
his smeared face withdrawn now from the
glare of the lamp
began to resume its normal appearance
presently he looked up at his guest
and said in his natural voice i hope
you've had enough to eat
you wouldn't care for this you know with
a downward glance
shorthouse met his eyes with an inward
loathing and it was impossible not to
show some of the repugnance he felt
in the other's face however he thought
he saw a subdued cowed expression
but he found nothing to say marx will be
in presently
garvey went on he's either listening or
in a vacuum
does he choose any particular time for
his visits the secretary managed to ask
he generally goes after dinner just
about this time in fact
but he's not gone yet he added shrugging
his shoulders
for i think i hear him coming shorthouse
wondered whether vacuum was possibly
synonymous with wine cellar but gave no
expression to his thoughts
with chills of horror still running up
and down his back he saw marks come in
with a basin and towel
while garvey thrust up his face just as
an animal puts up its muzzle to be
rubbed
now we'll have coffee in the library if
you're ready he said
in the tone of a gentleman addressing
his guests after a dinner party
short house picked up the bag which had
lain all this time between his feet
and walked through the door his host
held open for him
side by side they crossed the dark hall
together and to his disgust garvey
linked an arm in his
and with his face so close to the
secretary's ear that he felt the warm
breath
said in a thick voice you're uncommonly
careful with that bag mr shorthouse
it surely must contain something more
than a bundle of papers
nothing but the papers he answered
feeling the hand burning upon his arm
and wishing he were miles away from the
house and its abominable occupants
quite sure ask the other with an odious
and suggestive chuckle
is there any meat in it fresh meat raw
meat
the secretary felt somehow that at the
least sign of fear the beast on his arm
would leap upon him and tear him with
his teeth
nothing of the sword he answered
vigorously it wouldn't hold enough to
feed a cat
true said garvey with a vile sigh while
the other felt the hand upon his arm
twitch up and down as of feeling the
flesh
true it's too small to be of any real
use as you say
it wouldn't hold enough to feed a cat
shorthouse was unable to suppress a cry
the muscles of his fingers too relaxed
in spite of himself and he let the black
bag drop with a bang to the floor
garvey instantly withdrew his arm and
turned with a quick movement
but the secretary had regained his
control as suddenly as he had lost it
and he met the maniac's eyes with a
steady and aggressive glare
there you see it's quite light it makes
no appreciable noise when i drop it
he picked it up and let it fall again as
if he had dropped it for the first time
purposely
the ruse was successful yes you're right
garvey said still standing in the
doorway and staring at him
at any rate it wouldn't hold enough for
two he laughed
and as he closed the door the horrid
laughter echoed in the empty hall
they sat down by a blazing fire and
short house was glad to feel its warmth
marx presently brought in coffee a glass
of the old whiskey and a good cigar
helped to restore equilibrium
for some minutes the men sat in silence
staring into the fire
then without looking up garvey said in a
quiet voice
i suppose it was a shock to you to see
me eat raw meat like that
i must apologize if it was unpleasant to
you but it's all i can eat and it's the
only meal i take in the 24 hours
best nourishment in the world no doubt
though i should think it might be a
trifle strong for some stomachs
he tried to lead the conversation away
from so unpleasant a subject
and went on to talk rapidly of the
values of different foods
of vegetarianism and vegetarians and of
men who had gone for long periods
without any food at all
garvey listened apparently without
interest and had nothing to say
at the first pause he jumped in eagerly
when the hunger is really great on me he
said still gazing into the fire i simply
cannot control myself
i must have raw meat the first i can get
here he raised his shining eyes and
short house felt his hair beginning to
rise
it comes upon me so suddenly too i never
can tell when to expect it
a year ago the passion rose in me like a
whirlwind and marx was out and i
couldn't get a meal
i had to get something or i should have
bitten myself
just when it was getting unbearable my
dog ran out from beneath the sofa
it was a spaniel shorthouse responded
with an effort
he hardly knew what he was saying and
his skin crawled as if a million ants
were moving over it
there was a pause of several minutes
i've bitten marks all over garvey went
on presently in his strange quiet voice
and as if he was speaking of apples but
he's bitter
i doubt if the hunger could ever make me
do it again probably that's what first
drove him to take shelter in a vacuum
he chuckled hideously as he thought of
this solution of his attendance
disappearances
shorthouse seized the poker and poked
the fire as if his life depended on it
but when the banging and clattering was
over garvey continued his remarks with
the same calmness the next sentence
however was never finished
the secretary had got upon his feet
suddenly
i shall ask your permission to retire he
said in a determined voice
i'm tired tonight will you be good
enough to show me to my room
garvey looked up at him with a curious
cringing expression behind which they're
shown the gleam of cunning passion
certainly he said rising from his chair
you've had a tiring journey
i ought to have thought of that before
he took the candle from the table
and lit it and the fingers that held the
match trembled
we needn't trouble marks he explained
that beasts in his vacuum by this time
they crossed the hall and began to
ascend the carpetless wooden stairs
they were in the well of the house and
the air cut like ice
garvey the flickering candle in his hand
throwing his face into strong outline
led the way across the first landing and
opened a door near the mouth of a dark
passage
a pleasant room greeted the visitor's
eyes and he rapidly took in its points
while his host walked over
and lit two candles that stood on a
table at the foot of the bed
a fire burned brightly in the grate
there were two windows
opening like doors in the wall opposite
and a high canopied bed
occupied most of the space on the right
paneling ran all around the room
reaching nearly to the ceiling and gave
a warm and cozy appearance to the hole
while the portraits that stood in
alternate panels suggested somehow the
atmosphere of an old country house in
england
short house was agreeably surprised i
hope you'll find everything you need
garvey was saying in the doorway if not
you have only to ring that bell by the
fireplace
marx won't hear it of course but it
rings in my laboratory where i spend
most of the night
then with a brief good night he went out
and shut the door after him
the instant he was gone mr cybotham's
private secretary did a peculiar thing
he planted himself in the middle of the
room with his back to the door
and drawing the pistol swiftly from his
hip pocket leveled it across his left
arm at the window
standing motionless in this position for
30 seconds
he then suddenly swerved right around
and faced in the other direction
pointing his pistol straight at the
keyhole of the door
there followed immediately a sound of
shuffling outside and of steps
retreating across the landing
on his knees at the keyhole was the
secretary's reflection just as i thought
but he didn't expect to look down the
barrel of a pistol and it made him jump
a little
as soon as the steps had gone downstairs
and died away across the hall
short house went over and locked the
door stuffing a piece of crumpled paper
into the second keyhole
which he saw immediately above the first
after that he made a thorough search of
the room
it hardly repaid the trouble for he
found nothing unusual
yet he was glad he had made it it
relieved him to find no one was in
hiding under the bed
or in the deep oak cupboard and he hoped
sincerely it was not the cupboard in
which the unfortunate spaniel had come
to its vile death
the french windows he discovered opened
onto a little balcony
it looked onto the front and there was a
drop of less than 20 feet to the ground
below
the bed was high and wide soft as
feathers and covered with snowy sheets
very inviting to a tired man and beside
the blazing fire were a couple of deep
armchairs
altogether it was very pleasant and
comfortable but tired though he was
shorthouse had no intention of going to
bed it was impossible to disregard the
warning of his nerves
they had never failed him before and
when that sense of distressing horror
lodged in his bones
he knew there was something in the wind
and that a red flag was flying over the
immediate future
some delicate instrument in his being
more subtle than the senses
more accurate than mere pre-sentiment
had seen the red flag
and interpreted its meaning again it
seemed to him
as he sat in an armchair over the fire
that his movements were being carefully
watched from somewhere
and not knowing what weapons might be
used against him he felt that his real
safety lay in a rigid control of his
mind and feelings
and a stout refusal to admit that he was
in the least alarmed
the house was very still as the night
wore on the wind dropped
only occasional bursts of sleet against
the windows reminded him that the
elements were awake and uneasy
once or twice the windows rattled and
the rain hissed in the fire
but the roar of the wind and the chimney
grew less and less
and the lonely building was at last
lapped in a great stillness
the coals clicked settling themselves
deeper in the great
and the noise of the cinders dropping
with a tiny report into the soft heap of
accumulated ashes
was the only sound that punctuated the
silence
in proportion as the power of sleep grew
upon him the dread of the situation
lessened but so imperceptibly so
gradually
and so insinuatingly that he scarcely
realized the change
he thought he was as wide awake to his
danger as ever
the successful exclusion of horrible
mental pictures of what he had seen
he attributed to his rigorous control
instead of to their true cause
the creeping over him of the soft
influences of sleep
the faces in the coals were so soothing
the armchair was so comfortable
so sweet the breath that gently pressed
upon his eyelids
so subtle the growth of the sensation of
safety
he settled down deeper into the chair
and in another moment would have been
asleep
when the red flag began to shake
violently to and fro and he sat
bolt upright as if he had been stabbed
in the back
someone was coming up the stairs the
boards creaked beneath a stealthy weight
shorthouse sprang from the chair and
crossed the room swiftly
taking up his position beside the door
but out of range of the keyhole
the two candles flared unevenly on the
table at the foot of the bed
the steps were slow and cautious it
seemed 30 seconds between each one
but the person who was taking them was
very close to the door
already he had topped the stairs and was
shuffling almost silently across the bit
of landing
the secretary slipped his hand into his
pistol pocket and drew back further
against the wall
and hardly had he completed the movement
when the sounds abruptly ceased
and he knew that somebody was standing
just outside the door
and preparing for a careful observation
through the keyhole
he was in no sense a coward in action he
was never afraid
it was the waiting and wondering and the
uncertainty that might have loosened his
nerves a little
but somehow a wave of intense horror
swept over him for a second
as he thought of the bestial maniac and
his attendant servant
and he would rather have faced a pack of
wolves than have to do with either of
these men
something brushing gently against the
door set his nerves tingling afresh and
made him tighten his grasp on the pistol
the steel was cold and slippery in his
moist fingers
what an awful noise it would make when
he pulled the trigger
if the door were to open how close he
would be to the figure that came in
yet he knew it was locked on the inside
and could not possibly open
again something brushed against the
panel beside him and a second later the
piece of crumpled paper fell
from the keyhole to the floor while the
piece of thin wire that had accomplished
this result
showed its point for a moment in the
room and then was swiftly withdrawn
somebody was evidently peering now
through the keyhole and realizing this
fact the spirit of attack
entered into the heart of the
beleaguered man raising aloft his right
hand he brought it suddenly down with a
resounding crash upon the panel of the
door next to the keyhole
a crash that to the crouching
eavesdropper must have seemed like a
clap of thunder out of a clear sky
there was a gasp and a slight lurching
against the door and the midnight
listener rose startled and alarmed
her short house plainly heard the tread
of feet across the landing and down the
stairs
till they were lost in the silences of
the hall only this time it seemed to him
there were four feet instead of two
quickly stuffing the paper back into the
keyhole he was in the act of walking
back to the fireplace
when over his shoulder he caught sight
of a white face pressed an outline
against the outside of the window
it was blurred in the streams of sleet
but the white of the moving eyes was
unmistakable
he turned instantly to meet it but the
face was withdrawn like a flash
and darkness rushed in to fill the gap
where it had appeared
watched on both sides he reflected
but he was not to be surprised into any
sudden action
and quietly walking over to the
fireplace as if he had seen nothing
unusual
he stirred the coals a moment and then
strolled leisurely over to the window
stealing his nerves which quivered a
moment in spite of his will
he opened the window and stepped out
onto the balcony
the wind which he thought had dropped
rushed past him into the room and
extinguished one of the candles
while a volley of fine cold rain burst
all over his face
at first he could see nothing and the
darkness came close up to his eyes like
a wall
he went a little farther onto the
balcony and drew the window after him
till it clashed
then he stood and waited but nothing
touched him
no one seemed to be there his eyes got
accustomed to the blackness and he was
able to make out the iron railing
the dark shapes of the trees beyond and
the faint light coming from the other
window
through this he peered into the room
walking the length of the balcony to do
so
of course he was standing in a shaft of
light and whoever was crouching in the
darkness below could plainly see him
below that there should be anyone above
did not occur to him
until just as he was preparing to go in
again he became aware that something was
moving in the darkness over his head
he looked up instinctively raising a
protecting arm
and saw a long black line swinging
against the dim wall of the house
the shutters of the window on the next
floor once it depended
were thrown open and moved backwards and
forwards in the wind
the line was evidently a thickish cord
for as he looked it was pulled in
and the end disappeared in the darkness
shorthouse trying to whistle to himself
peered over the edge of the balcony as
if calculating the distance he might
have to drop
and then calmly walked into the room
again and closed the window behind him
leaving the latch so that the lightest
touch would cause it to fly open
he relit the candle and drew a straight
back chair up to the table
then he put coal on the fire and stirred
it up into a royal blaze
he would willingly have folded the
shutters over those staring windows at
his back
but that was out of the question it
would have been to cut off his way of
escape
sleep for the time was at a disadvantage
his brain was full of blood and every
nerve was tingling
he felt as if countless eyes were upon
him and scores of stained hands were
stretching out from the corners and
crannies of the house to seize him
crouching figures stood everywhere about
him where shelter was
creeping forward out of the shadows when
he was not looking and retreating
swiftly and silently when he turned his
head
wherever he looked other eyes met his
own and though they melted away under
his steady confident gaze
he knew they would wax and draw in upon
him the instant his glances weakened and
his will wavered
though there were no sounds he knew that
in the well of the house there was
movement going on
and preparation and this knowledge in as
much as it came to him irresistibly
and through other and more subtle
channels than those of the senses
kept the sense of horror fresh in his
blood and made him alert and awake
but no matter how great the dread in the
heart the power of sleep will eventually
overcome it
exhausted nature is irresistible and as
the minutes wore
on and midnight passed he realized that
nature was vigorously asserting herself
and sleep was creeping upon him from the
extremities
to lessen the danger he took out his
pencil and began to draw the articles of
furniture in the room
he worked into elaborate detail the
cupboard the mantelpiece
and the bed and from these he passed on
to the portraits
being possessed to genuine skill he
found the occupation sufficiently
absorbing
it kept the blood in his brain and that
kept him awake
the pictures moreover now that he
considered them for the first time
were exceedingly well painted owing to
the dim light he centered his attention
upon the portraits beside the fireplace
on the right was a woman
with a sweet gentle face and a figure of
great refinement
on the left was a full-size figure of a
big handsome man with a full beard
and wearing a hunting costume of ancient
date
from time to time he turned to the
windows behind him but the vision of the
face was not repeated
more than once too he went to the door
and listened but the silence was so
profound in the house
that he gradually came to believe the
plan of attack had been abandoned
once he went out onto the balcony but
the sleet stung his face
and he only had time to see that the
shutters above were closed
when he was obliged to seek the shelter
of the room again
in this way the hours passed the fire
died down and the room grew chilly
short house had made several sketches of
the two heads and was beginning to feel
overpoweringly weary
his feet and his hands were cold and his
yawns were prodigious
it seemed ages and ages since the steps
had come to listen at his door and the
face had watched him from the window
a feeling of safety had somehow come to
him in reality he was exhausted
his one desire was to drop upon the soft
white bed and yield himself up to sleep
without any further struggle he rose
from his chair with a series of yawns
that refused to be stifled
and looked at his watch it was close
upon three in the morning
he made up his mind that he would lie
down with his clothes on and get some
sleep
it was safe enough the door was locked
on the inside and the window was
fastened
putting the bag on the table near his
pillow he blew out the candles and
dropped with a sense of careless and
delicious exhaustion
upon the soft mattress in five minutes
he was sound asleep
there had scarcely been time for the
dreams to come when he found himself
lying sideways across the bed with wide
open eyes staring into the darkness
someone had touched him and he had
writhed away and his sleep is from
something unholy
the movement had awakened him the room
was simply black
no light came from the windows and the
fire had gone out as completely as if
water had been poured upon it
he gazed into a sheet of impenetrable
darkness that came close up to his face
like a wall
his first thought was for the papers in
his coat and his hand flew to the pocket
they were safe and the relief caused by
this discovery left his mind instantly
free for other reflections
and the realization that it once came to
him with a touch of dismay
was that during his sleep some definite
change had been affected in the room
he felt this with an intuitive certainty
which amounts to positive knowledge
the room was utterly still but the
corroboration that was speedily brought
to him seemed at once to fill the
darkness
with a whispering secret life that
chilled his blood and made the sheet
feel like ice against his cheek
hark this was it there reached his ears
in which the blood was already buzzing
with warning clamor
a dull murmur of something that rose
indistinctly from the well of the house
and became audible to him without
passing through walls or doors
there seemed no solid surface between
him lying on the bed
and the landing between the landing and
the stairs and between the stairs and
the hall beyond
he knew that the door of the room was
standing open
therefore it had been open from the
inside yet the window was fastened
also on the inside hardly was this
realized when the conspiring silence of
the hour was broken by another
and a more definite sound a step was
coming along the passage
a certain bruise on the hip told
shorthouse that the pistol in his pocket
was ready for use
and he drew it out quickly and cocked it
then he just had time to slip over the
edge of the bed
and crouched down on the floor when the
step halted on the threshold of the room
the bed was thus between him and the
open door the window was at his back
he waited in the darkness what struck
him as peculiar about the steps was that
there seemed no particular desire to
move stealthily
there was no extreme caution they moved
along in rather a slip shot way
and sounded like soft slippers or feet
in stockings
there was something clumsy irresponsible
almost reckless about the movement
for a second the steps paused upon the
threshold but only for a second
almost immediately they came on into the
room and as they passed from the wood to
the carpet
shorthouse noticed that they became
wholly noiseless he waited in suspense
not knowing whether the unseen walker
was on the other side of the room
or was close upon him presently he stood
up and stretched out his left arm in
front of him
groping searching feeling in a circle
and behind it he held the pistol
cocked and pointed in his right hand as
he rose a bone cracked in his knee
his clothes rustled as if they were
newspapers and his breath seemed loud
enough to be heard all over the room
but not a sound came to betray the
position of the invisible intruder
then just when the tension was becoming
unbearable a noise relieved the gripping
silence
it was wood knocking against wood and it
came from the farther end of the room
the steps had moved over to the
fireplace a sliding sound almost
immediately followed it
and then silence closed again over
everything like a pawl
for another five minutes short house
waited and then the suspense became too
much
he could not stand that open door the
candles were close beside him and he
struck a match and lit them
expecting in the sudden glare to receive
at least a terrific blow
but nothing happened and he saw it once
that the room was entirely empty
walking over with the pistol cocked he
peered out into the darkness of the
landing
and then closed the door and turned the
key then he searched the room
bed cupboard table curtains everything
that could have concealed a man
but found no trace of the intruder the
owner of the footsteps had disappeared
like a ghost into the shadows of the
night
but for one fact he might have imagined
that he had been dreaming
the bag had vanished there was no more
sleep for short house that night
his watch pointed to 4 am and there were
still 3 hours before daylight
he sat down at the table and continued
his sketches
with fixed determination he went on with
his drawing and began a new outline of
the man's head
there was something in the expression
that continually evaded him
he had no success with it and this time
it seemed to him that it was the eyes
that brought about his discomfort
he held up his pencil before his face to
measure the distance between the nose
and the eyes
and to his amazement he saw that a
change had come over the features
the eyes were no longer open the lids
had closed
for a second he stood in a sort of
stupefied astonishment
a push would have toppled him over then
he sprang to his feet and held a candle
close up to the picture the eyelids
quivered the eyelashes trembled
then right before his gaze the eyes
opened and looked straight into his own
two holes were cut in the panel and this
pair of eyes
human eyes just fitted them as by a
curious effect of magic
the strong fear that had governed him
ever since his entry into the house
disappeared in a second anger rushed
into his heart and his chilled blood
rose suddenly to boiling point
putting the candle down he took two
steps back into the room and then flung
himself forward with all his strength
against the painted panel
instantly and before the crash came the
eyes were withdrawn
and two black spaces showed where they
had been the old huntsman was
eyeless but the panel cracked and split
inwards like a sheet of thin cardboard
and short house pistol in hand thrust an
arm through the jagged aperture
and seizing a human leg dragged out into
the room
the servant words rushed in such a
torrent to his lips that they choked him
the old man white as chalk stood shaking
before him
the bright pistol barrel opposite his
eyes when a volume of cold air rushed
into the room
and withered a sound of hurried steps
shorthouse felt his arm knocked up
before he had time to turn
and the same second garvey who had
somehow managed to burst open the window
came between him and the trembling marks
his lips were parted
and his eyes rolled strangely in his
distorted face
don't shoot him shoot in the air he
shrieked he sees the man by the
shoulders
you damned hound he roared hissing into
his face so i've got you at last
that's where your vacuum is is it i know
your vile hiding place at last
he shook him like a dog i've been after
him all night he cried
turning to short house all night i tell
you and i've got him at last
garvey lifted his upper lip as he spoke
and showed his teeth
they shone like the fangs of a wolf the
servant evidently saw them too
for he gave a horrid yell and struggled
furiously
before the eyes of the secretary a mist
seemed to rise
the hideous shadow again leaped into
garvey's face
he foresaw a dreadful battle and
covering the two men with his pistol he
retreated slowly to the door
whether they were both mad or both
criminal he did not pause to inquire
the only thought present in his mind was
that the sooner he made his escape the
better
garvey was still shaking the old man
when he reached the door and turned the
key
but as he passed out onto the landing
both men stopped their struggling and
turned to face him
garvey's face bestial loathsome livid
with anger
the servants white and gray with fear
and horror both turned towards him and
joined in a wild horrible yell that woke
the echoes of the night
the next second they were after him at
full speed
short house slammed the door in their
faces and was at the foot of the stairs
crouching in the shadow
before they were out upon the landing
they tore shrieking down the stairs and
passed him into the hall
and wholly unnoticed shorthouse whipped
up the stairs again
crossed the bedroom and dropped from the
balcony into the soft snow
as he ran down the drive he heard behind
him in the house the yells at the
maniacs
and when he reached home several hours
later mr sidebotham
not only raised his salary but also told
him to buy a new hat and overcoat
and send in the bill to him
you